la place des arts beau être déserte en
coulisses ça court mais faute de pouvoir
accueillir le public dans les salles et
grâce au financement de québec le
théâtre jean duceppe à montréal opus se
tourner vers les laboratoires théa trop
l'idée de base c'était de faire
travailler le plus d'artistes mais aussi
de faire ça de façon constructive donc
pas juste par une enveloppe financière
65 artistes et artisans ont été engagés
pour ces laboratoires
c'est deux fois plus que pour une demi
saison normale le public pourra voir sur
le web
cette incursion inédite au coeur du
processus de création
si rare qu'on a la chance d'être là
présent aux premières étapes aux
balbutiements d'un projet etc etc c'est
vraiment important pour nous aussi de
deux heures en accessibles ses
laboratoires à l'eau au public si la
formule est nouvelle à du 7 au théâtre
du double signe à sherbrooke les
laboratoires de création sont dans l'adn
de la compagnie en création
le temps c'est de l'argent mais c'est
aussi surtout des idées faut se méfier
des recettes un pitre quand on tombe
dans les modes de production tout est
assez paramétrer je pense que à l'image
d'un laboratoire pour la science dans
son bain ce qui est intéressant dans un
laboratoire de création c'est de voir
une hypothèse claire de départ d' objet
d'étude mais ensuite deux heures
peut-être que c'est pas le bon angle ou
que c'est pas la bonne hypothèse puis
d'un revoir complètement une nouvelle
idée aux besoins j'obéirai bien à
montréal au théâtre du nouveau monde
aussi on s'est tournés par la formule
labour à compter de vendredi
les spectateurs pourront découvrir le
laboratoire de création publique du
roman de monsieur molière
j'ai pris le pari de donner le théâtre
de donner le théâtre dans l'écran avec
avec le coffre avec des expressions
faciales que prépa à la télé lors que je
ferais pas au cinéma temps de voir ce
que les gens vont en penser tu doit
bénir leur d'état destinée
je sens extrêmement privilégié en tant
qu'interprète de pouvoir participer à
quelque chose comme ce ne serait ce que
parce qu'on sait que ça va atteindre un
certain public et des gens qui demandent
encore dans leurs salons de pouvoir
toucher d'entendre du théâtre de pouvoir
voir du théâtre en cette saison
théâtrale bouleversé par la compagnie
l'émergence des laboratoires de création
est la preuve que de l'adversité pu
naître de belles occasions
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]